hello and welcome to The Economist tasks
I'm your host and MacElroy and this week
we're asking what's the role of religion
in a divided society appointed in 2015
the most reverent Michael Curry is the
first african-american Presiding Bishop
of the Episcopal Church the American
branch of Anglicanism he's been active
in arguments often very fraught ones
about the church on gay marriage and
he's described Donald Trump's
america-first doctrine as a theological
heresy he sparked a debate about the
role of religion in the era of populism
and trouble but his renown outside the
rights of the faithful probably stems
from that wedding he was invited to give
a sermon at the Royal Wedding of Prince
Harry and Megan Markel in May earlier
this year he became world famous
overnight immortalized in a Saturday
Night Live sketch to boot
Bishop Carey welcome thank you it could
have a start
thank you let's dive in on the wedding
because that's where so many people will
know you from how did your invitation
come about what was your response well
the the the royal couple ultimately made
the decision and that was communicated
to me via the Archbishop of Canterbury
and at first I didn't really know how to
respond because there was a part of me
he spoke with a member of my staff and
the member of my staff found me I was
enroute somewhere and I thought the
member of my staff was kidding me
I said surely you were kidding and it
was it could it just took a while to
realize is this really happening and the
archbishop was most gracious and
conveying their desire and of course you
say yes of course no glad to do it it
was a particularly it was quite a fiery
by literally fiery soul of mentions of
love and fire a shocker to some of the
more staid members of the Anglican
Church and possibly some of the
congregation of
waiting well you know I suspect the the
what what I've found is that the the
response to the sermon that I've run
into most frequently has actually been
around the theme of love that I think
one of the important things that that's
really going on is we in Christianity
are really trying to reclaim the core
and the essence of the faith of Jesus of
Nazareth and if you really look at Jesus
of Nazareth very carefully you will
discover that at his core at the center
is the way of love now I'm not talking
about a sentimental kind of love and
there's nothing wrong with that but
that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about the way a way of
love that is centered on unselfish
sacrificial living that seeks the good
and the welfare of others before one's
own unenlightened self-interest and that
way of love is a spiritual discipline
it's a it's a way of life it's a
practice and that way of love actually
changes interpersonal relationships
personal relationships social political
global that way of love sacrificial love
which is what dr. King was talking about
based on the teachings of Jesus that way
of love that's a game-changer in human
relationships and what about the the
style and the great can Flair with which
you delivered it oh did you feel this is
a bit interesting being in Windsor
Chapel it's a much more formal setting
there are occasional excitements in
Anglican Church in Britain but then it's
not generally the style of the sermon
and did you consider that
well you I'm probably I'm an American
and so the the American experience is
America as it was settled and as as
America America evolved the the frontier
became the the setting when much
preaching happened by itinerant
preachers who traveled on horseback and
that guy
thing and so I probably reflect that
American spirit and in that respect but
I have to tell you the congregation they
were wonderful I've been a parish pastor
a long time before was Bishop and one of
the things I learned was how do you hear
someone saying an Amen not with their
lips but with their eyes give me a name
they may be absolutely quiet but if
they're looking at you intently they're
giving me their version of an amen and
so everybody doesn't have to shout to be
with you everybody don't have to clap
their hands to be with you but if you
watch their eyes you can tell if they're
asleep or if they're really listening to
the message and taking it in in their
own way and I looked at the congregation
present and in their way they were
taking the message in and that's all you
ever want that works now I'm going to be
a bit cheeky in us did you have
difficulty keeping to time you were you
went a little bit longer I think he did
my high-level contact sent to the palace
here but no I'm joking with you on that
it was quite a generously flowing sermon
did you suddenly think I get off waiting
to go with absolutely sure well you know
there it was funny because there was a
part in the sermon one of the things
that was important was the text the
Bible text that they selected was you
know the song of song or the song of
Solomon's there's a book in the Bible
that's often overlooked and and I've
preached many weddings but that was the
first time I've actually preached on
that particular text at a wedding
but it's love poetry but between two
lovers who are about to be married and
they express their love and vivid and
dramatic and romantic language but the
text itself the text itself comes from
near the end when the woman realizes
that their love for each other this
incredible experience of love that there
having the wait a minute is it's coming
from somewhere else it's coming from a
greater love now are you telling me
there because you had to get your Botox
that's exactly what I'm telling that
this is a remarkable text that because
this they Rishi realizes that the source
of this love is not generated by them
the source of this love is God
the God who created them now stop and
imagine what that means if that's true
if that's true then they knew answering
the question I am I'm actually doing
here cuz I'm taking time answering it
I'm sure and you would it what happens
when you literally enter the world of
the biblical text and let God begin to
speak to us so now I had to do that in a
short period of time and so I actually
did condense it and and there was there
was a point toward the end of the sermon
you may notice when I said now we've got
it we've got to get you all married so
let me finish this up
that was that was sort of a way of
saying give me a permission let me just
finish this sermon and that's where I
had one other piece where I talked about
de chardin
which really did bring home the point
that this love is the fire that creates
life itself and a note for life and so
yet took a little bit longer but I think
it's worth the time what do you think
that the role of the monarchy now and
how do you think making mark eventually
into the royal family and Britain will
change that you know I have I have
nothing but the utmost respect for the
royal family and and I have to tell you
and I'm you know I can't get into any
details or I can't tell you anything
about you know what's going on within or
without but what I do know I see some
human beings who are trying to help the
rest of us learn how to be human beings
and family together and I think that
wedding I mean just just think about
that wedding it brought together see
that wedding was a sign of what love can
do that wedding brought together Britain
in the United States I mean you know
we're allies and friends and all of that
kind of stuff but it brought two very
different cultures together that wedding
brought a variety of coat
within the within England within Britain
in terms of the music you had the boys
boys and men's choir
you had the Gospel Choir you had that
cellist you had a variety of worlds were
brought together that is a sign what
about mark she comes as you say from
America that brings the two worlds
together
she also is from a new society very
different she's she's entering into and
she has an african-american heritage in
it not from her mother's side what
difference do you think will she shake
up the royal family I'm not gonna get
into that what time will tell let me
tell you what happened at when that all
of that heritage all of that history
that she brings all of the history that
he brings those two worlds came together
and they looked at each other with the
adoring eyes of love all I know is that
love that they have between each other
brought different worlds together it
brought people from around the world
together to see the wedding
it really did it brought people of
different I've talked to people of
different political persuasions liberals
and conservatives who just rejoiced at
the love that they saw if that happened
at the wedding will imagine what will
happen with the rest of their lives but
better than that imagine no imagine what
can happen with our lives in the life of
the world
this way of love let me finish
hold on my sister hold on my sister hold
on this way of love changes everything
it makes space for all of us that's what
we saw and that's the hope for all of us
so what should they do you've got this
lovely young royal couple oh you've got
to know a little bit thoroughly and
enjoying the day what should they do
what should they bring
in the spirit of what you discuss what
should they bring into the royal family
this time in Britain in the world let me
tell you what we should all bring we who
are human beings they're humans like the
rest of us we were children of God what
we need to bring is that spirit of love
that is sacrificial that really does
look for the good of others
above and beyond my own self-interest
what would I mean it's just drifting off
in a little bit what would that mean
what would you like to see see I can't I
can't enter into that I really can't
because I'm an American it would be
presumptuous for me to speak for them
that that's not much I can tell you what
it means here I can tell you what I
think it means in the world see what it
means in the world is that we are going
to be passionately committed about the
abolition of poverty in the world it
means we're going to do whatever we have
to do to bring war to an end in the
world it means we're going to do
whatever we have to do to clean up this
environment so that we do not destroy
God's creation I mean I that's what that
mean that's what I'm interested in
passionate about and and so that changes
everything for the good so let's let's
talk about that I mean one thing that
the wedding to give you it was a huge
that form for your kind of views about
religion in the world and you're very
strongly identified here I think with a
kind of progressive Church somewhat
small P progressive but the church that
takes on progressive social values what
stops people who cleave to that at a
time when we tend to live too much in
bubbles and we've seen a lot of the
political consequences of that perhaps
particularly here in the US but also
beyond it what stops people then say you
know I found my progressive Church I
found a nice
progressive bishop who's in charge of it
and so I really don't need to question
my values anymore because he's on the
same side I'm on a pro gay marriage
Make Poverty History all those good
causes actually you know I mean the
truth is the among Episcopalians here in
the United States I would have to say
that we would the the average population
of Episcopalians would be a Mick you
have conservative Republicans Liberal
Democrats progressive and just plain
independent independents I mean it
really is a church of real political
diversity actually we are probably
rightfully characterized as progressive
on some question social questions before
us but on other questions I think our
people hold a variety of perspectives
now give you a good example of what I
think really is critical on the one hand
one can be progressive or traditional
and yet are you remain in the midst of
it all and do you make room in space for
people who disagree with you give me a
contributor example I mean what have you
changed that's that's where I was head
that's exactly where you
we're on the same line that that
literally this church we were a church
where we allow for the marriage of
same-sex couples and we believe that
that when people are in love and they're
committing themselves to to the fullness
of life they ought to have that
possibility and not to have the blessing
of God in the church on that but we are
also a choice so we we allow for that
and make a space for that but we're also
a church where there are people who do
not believe in that and literally at
this last general convention of the
Episcopal Church where we make decisions
about governing our lives we made
provision to make sure that both of
those integrities both of those
positions are respected and honored
because the people who hold them are all
children of God and so we are living
actually with those differences as one
church and I would submit that's a model
that's that's a model for how we can
live together in human community and
society let's talk directly about Donald
Trump you said that America first as far
as you're concerned is a theological
heresy
you also ended up really being pulled
perhaps towards a protest movement
against Trump how do you draw the line
where religion should stop and where in
politics starts well actually the the
protest for example that you're
mentioning was a prayer visual it wasn't
a protest wasn't it was a prayer vigil
we started in a church we had sermons we
read scripture we sang hymns we spoke of
how the holy scriptures apply in our
context but we did not we prayed for the
end of poverty we prayed for the
establishment of justice we prayed for
the President of the United States
whether we agree or disagree prayed for
him and then we walked in a silent
processional candlelight processional to
the White House at the White House we
sang to him this little light of mine
I'm gonna let it shine Jesus gave it to
me I'm gonna let it shine
and then we prayed and then we stated
the affirmations that that you're
referring to one of one of those
affirmations we read those affirmations
and we prayed that we might live them
and that our nation might live them this
this was a prayer vigil and and that's
really what we were is attached yes it
was a religious message that had
political and social implications but
not a political message first a
religious one because we wouldn't our
text was we're Christians and we have
been taught that Jesus said you shall
love your neighbor as yourself that is
God's law that is God's Way and that
must also be reflected in our social
policy so so we began we really did we
began from a religious base and and it's
important to know that the group that
brought that together the reclaiming
Jesus this group was composed of Roman
Catholic mainline Protestant
evangelicals it was composed of people
who are Republicans and people who are
Democrats and in others it was a
broad-based group of people who disagree
on a number of issues but we agreed on
the values of G
that that every human being must be
treated what did you want Donald Trump
to do differently as a result what did
you realistically expect that a
president of Donald we want chubby one
oh we want not just Donald Trump we want
our country to reflect the values that
have made America great that that as
Thomas Jefferson said I mean the
Declaration of Independence we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal that all people
are created equal and endowed by the
creator not voted by any government
endowed by the creator with certain
inalienable rights that among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness we want our country to reflect
its founding documents to reflect what
we say in the Declaration of
Independence we want we I know but you
say Whitman we want our country to
reflect the Pledge of Allegiance that I
was taught as a child in school and
children to this day stand pledge
allegiance one nation under God
indivisible with indivisible with
liberty and justice for all we want to
be a country where there is justice for
all I stay with me a country where there
is justice for all does not separate
children from their mothers when they
are refugees trying to immigrate into
this country we do it it's just what is
kind what is decent what is right and
when America does what is right and good
and just and decent then and only then
is America great I know you are I'm with
got through sensitive the White House in
this incarnation is sensitive to the
relative religions I can't tell you
specifically about how the White House
was sensitive to the role of religion in
this context but I can tell you more
broadly the as a result of that prayer
vigil we encouraged all of the leaders
who were there and all of the people who
were there to participate in similar
prayer vigils especially around the
detention of children
at our borders and they were doing that
and we did that as Episcopalians when we
were at our general convention some 12
busloads of Episcopalians left the
convention I was one of them and we that
we adjourned recessed part of the
convention for a while we went to a
detention center there near if Texas
where women were incarcerated these were
women who were trying to immigrate to
the country excuse me who were trying to
imitate to immigrate to the country who
had been separated from their children
and we held the same kind of prayer
vigil there now that was happy that kind
of thing was happening all over the
country and so we were part of a
creative but I want you to hear that we
were part of a ferment that was
beginning to build in this country it
wasn't just us and as a result of that
the government did alter its policy so
it didn't completely change but it did
have an impact that's what do you think
the Donald Trump acts in good faith he's
a good person I'm not going to judge
your soul that's as the Pope said Who am
I to judge
only God knows that what I know are the
policies that are going on what I know
are the actions that are going on and
and I want my country to reflect humane
actions that are decent and honorable
and that reflect what I believe to be
the values and teachings of Jesus of
Nazareth I want to be I want my country
I love my country but I want my country
to be a country where love of neighbor
really matters so what would you say you
say you don't judge Donald Trump it in
the way you are judging you were judging
his policies you're judging his outlook
it's it's yeah the policies I'm judging
follows well let's talk about the man as
the conduit for the policies do you
believe that you act in good faith
that's not mine I don't even it's
irrelevant right it's irrelevant what
matters are the policies what matters is
what he does and I disagree with
separating children from their
I disagree when the president doesn't
speak when Nazis are marching through
the streets and clansmen are marching
through the streets and my president
does not condemn that I disagree with
that so I want to stay focused on the
real issues that are at stake I disagree
when we're not giving adequate support
to public education where most of our
children and certainly the children of
the poor received their education I want
to stay on the issues that are affecting
people it's easy to argue about Donald
Trump or any politician we must focus on
the things that actually impact people
well would you pray for a different
outcome in the next election in that
case what a good question one must
always be careful and not telling God
what to do what I would do pray for is
that we will elect leaders who are just
who are righteous who are loving who are
compassionate and who are wise that I do
pray for I must ask you about your own
background and it's you know tell us a
little bit of your own story but I'm
particularly interested in this rule was
the first african-american presiding
bishop in the job looks back to the
wedding what how strange was it to go
back and be among an establishment very
connected to the slave trade did you
feel shiver down your spine no because
I've been a descendant of slaves my
whole life and I've had to live in the
context of the American establishment my
whole life I grew up an african-american
in the Episcopal Church the American
branch of Anglicanism so this is the
world I've learned to live in and I
actually have have learned to live in
and to be honest I was at home when when
you have been a minority in a majority
context you learned how to navigate the
context and I just grew up
go to a place in Windsor Castle might be
one or any major part of the historical
kind of institutions and feel ghosts no
no no more than I would in the American
South you know as I've learned to
navigate that and to live with that here
in the context where my ancestors
actually were slaves I was in Ghana a
few years ago and at the door of no
return and and could feel the presence
and a sense of of something but the
painful happened here you could actually
feel that you know that that's all part
of our history and heritage but that's
just but I feel that here as well as in
Ghana or Britain or wherever that's part
of our history but one of the things
that we tell you dr. King said said
before his death and he started
repeating this he said you know we will
either learn to live together as
brothers and sisters a whole parish
together as fool's
he said the choice is ours chaos or
community I believe we've got to find a
way to community if we learn to live
together as brothers and sisters
acknowledging the pain of our past and
now living in the present we can write a
new future and I really believe that
that's all work I'm just wondering
whether you're thinking you might end up
getting back to Britain for a rural
baptism at some point I don't that's not
my I don't that's not something I get
into I don't they that's not a decision
that's mine but actually that's probably
my guess is that's the Church of England
that's a proof really they're their
domain you leap it you've been a strong
proponent of gay marriage welcoming gay
marriage in the church puts you at odds
with Canterbury with the at least the
official position of the Anglican
Communion in England how do you feel
about that
remember earlier I said it is important
for us to learn to get live together
even with
our differences I love the Church of
England and the people of the Church of
England then the archbishop and we will
agree or disagree on a number of things
but love overcomes many differences he
thinks you're moving too fast really
doesn't seem about that I I believe in
what we have done here but we have not
only made provision for gay people to be
married in our church but we've also
made provision for people who disagree
with that to know that this church is
their home not that this is their home
too and and the capacity to make space
for others whether they agree or
disagree
I believe that's what Jesus Christ
teaches us to do it's a slightly more
complicated position when it comes to
transgender than it was do you feel that
there's any sort of intellectual tussle
there about sometimes competing rights
within sort of transgender LGBTQ and
whatever letters can't come after I mean
do you feel that those same rights can
apply across the board marriage for
instance well here in the Episcopal
Church they they do we believe that
every person is a child of God and those
who are part of the baptized community
whether you are gay straight bisexual
transgendered doesn't matte black white
conservative liberal rich poor all who
st. Paul says all who have been baptized
into Jesus Christ have put on Christ and
Paul goes on and says there is no longer
slave or free there is no longer male or
female there's no longer do you agree
but all are one in Christ and we believe
that all who want to follow the way of
Jesus we're all one in Christ no matter
who we are
Bishop Currie thank you very much for
joining us thank you it's been a
pleasure
you